welcome back everyone it's Charlie put
on a happy face because all the
Hollywood trades are reporting that
they're working on Joker - that's right
there will be some sort of sequel in the
next couple of years so we'll explain
what's going on if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there's a whole bunch of
stuff coming up and we're doing a DC
merch giveaway all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
all your predictions about Joker - on
the video so we'll just break this down
top ten style obviously careful for
spoilers from the first Joker movie if
you haven't seen that yet but because it
just made a billion dollars I'm assuming
that most of you watching this video
have already seen the movie so number
ten what just happened
The Joker movie just made over a billion
dollars at the box office making it DC
Comics most profitable movie of all time
and the highest earning rated R movie of
all time worldwide so no surprise that
this week there were reports from a
couple different Hollywood trades that
Warner Brothers is looking to do Joker -
with Todd Phillips and Joaquin Phoenix
now there are a couple conflicting
reports about what stage of development
that sequel is in and what things are
looking like behind the scenes but
number 9 where is Joker to actually add
in terms of development so on a scale of
them asking Todd Phillips to start
pitching Joker to ideas - they're
filming it being like the maximum based
on what different reports are saying it
sounds like Todd Phillips Joaquin
Phoenix and Warner Brothers are just
starting to talk about what Joker 2
might be there was a clip that I posted
right after the movie came out where
Joaquin Phoenix had started to talk
about what a sequel might be slowly
being interested in it because typically
he's not an actor that does sequels so
before the movie came out when they were
just doing early press on it people just
assumed that this was going to be the only
Joker movie it was going to be a one and
done up to that point Todd Phillips had
also been kind of non-committal about
what's going on after this what are you
going to do if this movie's successful he
just hadn't talked about it a lot so
there wasn't a lot of information about
what he was thinking so that clip was
from about a month ago right after the
movie hit theaters in Joaquin Phoenix
then said behind the scenes while they
were making the first movie they did
start to talk a little bit about what
they might do if they did a sequel but
at the time they hadn't committed to
doing anything nobody had signed any
contracts for potential sequels all the
stuff that they had done was just
for this one movie number eight this
morning as part of all this Joker to
sequel talk the Hollywood trades were
also reporting that Warner Brothers will
develop more DC black label movies about
their big villain characters regardless
of what happens with Joker - I think we
all expected when this movie came out
that it seems so big that they would
eventually try it with another Batman
villain or another Justice League
villain the only thing I would qualify
this statement with is that they're
probably not going to do any villains that
are currently being used by Matt Reeves
in his Batman movie coming up in 2021
at least right away so while explain
which ones are probably off-limits for
at least the next few years because
there are a lot of Batman villains
showing up in that new Batman movie with
Robert Pattinson but number seven is you
go without saying that whatever Joker -
winds up being in these other DC black
label movies with DC villains they'll
still be relatively small they only
spent about fifty fifty five million
dollars making the Joker movie so maybe
that budget goes up just a little bit
but one of the only reasons why Todd
Phillips was allowed to make Joker in
the first place he said was because the
budget was so small the risk was so low
to Warner Brothers that means that the
DC black label films won't have a ton of
crazy special effects or really huge
action scenes think about the ending of
the first Joker movie it seemed like a
big scene but relatively speaking it was
small compared to what you would see in
a traditional say Superman movie like
Man of Steel number 6 early production
in release date so if things don't fall
apart during early development I think
Joker too probably wouldn't happen for
at least four more years minimum because
even though there are a lot of
conflicting reports about where they're
at with this Joker - movie Todd Phillips
said that he wasn't going to do a sequel
just to cash in on box-office profits he
wouldn't do it until he found a story
that resonated as much as the story of
the first Joker movie all that is is
code for we're not going to be doing
anything right away so give him a good
solid four years before you hear
anything about Joker - actually coming
out we're talking 2023 by that time
Marvel will have already done their
Fantastic Four movie they'll be talking
about doing their first x-men movie
inside the MCU just as a benchmark
Aquaman - for example also not happening
until four years after the first Aquaman
movie came out now there's a number of
reasons why that's happening with that
franchise because the Aquaman franchise
is way more overtly commercial than the
joke
movie but getting into story predictions
and characters based on what they've
said and where they leave the character
at the end of the first Joker movie so
number 5 Joker - should still be a
relatively small self-contained movie
with the Joker still thinking himself a
hero of the people like the mob of all
the Joker masked people lifting him up
at the end of the first movie
celebrating him so he feels like the
hero of his own movie even though you
can never really trust his perspective
what's real what's fake was just
happening inside of his head in order to
do that though you need to either find
someone who's worse than the Joker or
pit him against the establishment again
the voice of authority or heroes that
traditionally represent the
establishment Law & Order versus the
chaos of the Joker and using the Joker's
perspective shifts just make it seem
like whoever the hero or whoever the
character you put in the movie against
them is the real villain whether or not
they're an actual villain from DC Comics
but you also continue to play with the
idea of what's real and what's fake and
what's only happening inside of his head
number four of course we should say that
there will still be no Batman in his
sequel movie mostly because Todd
Phillips said that Joaquin Phoenix's
Joker would never crossover with Robert
Pattinson 'he's Batman this is the clip
where he says that Robert Pattinson was
just cast as Batman I know this is a
totally different movie but but do you
see those two worlds merging together
anytime soon no I'm choosing to take him
at his word when he says that even
though I do think that Matt Reeves will
eventually use a different version of
the Joker inside his new Batman trilogy
the Joker is not supposed to appear in
the first new Batman movie the long
Halloween one that they're doing June
2021 so even though they try not to
double down on different types of
villains on-screen at the same time
eventually you will start to see
different DC black label characters
showing up that you've already seen in
the mainstream DC films I do think it's
possible for them to do a darker version
of Batman with in the DC Black Label
films but if they're trying to do a new
trilogy of Batman films with Robert
Pattinson I don't think that they would
allow multiple versions of Batman to
show up on screen and so that's another
six to seven years minimum with Robert
Pattinson before you can use another
version of Batman somewhere else so
number three because they're also going
to do other DC black label villain
movies and mostly avoiding characters
Matt Reeves is using at least for right
now that
means no Riddler no two-face no Catwoman
and no penguin but for the most part
pretty much anyone else is on the table
which is why you know thinking about the
Joker pitting himself against symbols of
authority it would be cool to see them
start doing a version of Lex Luthor
inside the DC black label universe so
number two talking about Superman a
little bit henry cavill just did an
interview saying that he still wants to
be Superman in DC Universe but aside
from a few rumors about Man of Steel -
it doesn't seem like there'll be another
Superman solo movie for at least three
to four years which means they're free
and clear to recast a new version of lex
luthor for the separate DC black label
universe that isn't connected to Justice
League or the Jesse Eisenberg version of
Lex Luthor we just kind of wiped that
clean don't have to worry about that
version of Lex Luthor anymore but
instead of doing a Lex Luthor origin
story right off the bat you introduced
him as the antagonist of another Joker
movie trying to take control of Gotham
City after the death of Thomas and
Martha Wayne
power abhors a vacuum Gotham is in chaos
during the Joker movie
Lex Luthor's alignment is staunch lawful
evil he loves imposing his own sense of
order on things in the Joker is all
about chaos Lex Luthor is probably the
most high-profile DC villain available
outside of the Joker that works on that
level he doesn't have any special powers
you don't need to use big special
effects he just has his evil genius
intellect and his desire for more power
so number one if things work out
long-term and they can introduce a
version of Lex Luthor inside a joker
movie or the DC black label universe
then you can spin him out into his own
solo movie after that and do a president
Lex storyline from the comics the story
of how Lex Luthor became President of
the United States they even did a
version of that on Smallville in the
alternate future of that show you just
see Michael Rosen poems show up in the
finale wearing this white suit after
having just been elected president of
the United States the other bonus of
taking that approach with the Lex Luthor
character is that you can also
reintroduce Henry Cavill Superman as one
of his villains during a future Lex
Luthor movie if things work out
long-term no Superman isn't a villain
but if the movies being shot from Lex
Luthor's perspective he sees Superman as
a villain Superman would be the
antagonist of that film right now
there's no official word on what the
future of Superman at
DC is other than they will use the
character in other upcoming movies
eventually and eventually do a new solo
Superman movie for those of you that
really want Henry Cavill to come back
best odds short term for Henry Cavill
coming back are probably through a black
atom sequel because Henry cavils
management team is seven bucks and
that's the company that the rock owns
his ex-wife runs that company so they
are best buds and Henry Cavill is one of
the few actors that has the physique to
seem like a threat to the rocks black
atom in fact a couple years ago the rock
actually reached out to boss logic who
does a lot of fan art and asked him to
draw a picture of him as black atom
fighting Henry Cavill Superman so it
sounds like the rock really wants to
fight Superman in one of his movies but
everyone post all your Joker to theories
in the comments below and I will do more
videos about it when we get more details
right now I don't have any plans for
videos about alternate cuts of Justice
League but if they actually release one
that we can watch then I will totally do
a video about that there's a bunch of
stuff coming up I've got a new flash
crisis on Infinite Earths trailer video
that I'll post tonight while you wait
for that click here for all my Joker
Easter eggs and ending videos and click
here for my Star Wars the Mandalorian
episode 2 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!